cette vue remarquable sur la rivière
pentecôte risque bientôt de n'être que
chose du passé à quelque 2 km de
l'embouchure le bras de la rivière érode
la berge du côté de la mère au point de
bientôt créer une brèche qui pourrait
changer le tracé du cours d'eau un
certain point il ne reste plus qu'une
douzaine de mètres entre la rivière et
le saint laurent
on a autant les professeurs skopje où on
ne les vagues qui vont venir frapper sur
la côte est où on a aussi la boucle de
meilhan donc l'érosion latéral à
l'intérieur de la berge donc on a les
deux processus le surplace donc il
pourrait suffire d'une crue importante
ou d'une tempête automnale majeur pour
que l'embouchure de la rivière change de
visage
aucune étude ne permet de prédire la
suite des événements
la géographie d'autres rivières de la
côte nord laisse présager la formation
d'un marais dans l'embouchure un
excellent milieu humide pour abriter la
faune et la flore c'est un cas qui est
extrêmement intéressant et qui est un
peu comparable au coeur de port neuf sur
mer ou en 1938 on a eu une crue très
grande qui a fait en sorte que la
rivière traverse est complètement le
banc de sable donc la flèche littoral
est aujourd'hui l'ancien lit de la
rivière est devenue marie marine
j'ai été à même de constater tout les
changements l'érosion en quantité
industrielle
le maire de port cartier se souvient
d'une époque où circulaient des
véhicules sur le banc de sable avance au
tabac même un terrain de tempé thabet
puis où ce qui est déjà pu aller
s'approvisionner péta qu'aujourd'hui
mais depuis capable de possibles donc
c'est juste une question de temps avant
qu'un moment donné la riviera pas au
sens où ce que c'est que à peu près dans
le milieu de la pointe de la situation
les quais d'autant plus que mais qui de
rivière pentecôte encore utilisé par des
pêcheurs commerciaux risquent de devenir
désuet à l'heure actuelle doit s'il y en
a pas beaucoup doté à cause l'érosion
fidèle des sédiments qui sont descendus
vers la rivière donc c'est ce que ça va
changer de manière radicale va plus ça
va être fini pour les bateaux au pire le
lit de la rivière pentecôte est en fait
de sable son évolution à travers le
teint est dure à prévoir il se pourrait
même que des sédiments remblai la zone
est rodé ici jean louis bord de l'eau
radio-canada rivière pentecôte